let's go over to Dalia Muhammad Abdul
munim she is an activist and joins us
now by Skype also from Khartoum can you
give us an idea we were speaking moments
ago to our other guest who was talking
about the explosions that she can see
and hear and feel rocking her house tell
us what you're seeing
well I mean I don't know if you can hear
it but it's literally very heavy
artillery it's not just a normal gun
this is really heavy a Weaponry that's
being used I mean our house is shaking
it's been it's been shaking for a bit
now and I stepped out just to see and
all I could see was plumes of smoke
but honestly uh we're not venturing out
we're not going up anywhere because we
really don't know what's happening but
we are where I'm where I live is very
close to one of the bases of the
headquarters of the rsf so which is also
near like a five minute drive from the
pilot from the presidential Palace and
the main area of downtown Khartoum so I
guess this is where the majority of the
and if you can call it fighting is
taking place at this moment
all right and as you're talking to us
we're getting lines dropping here stay
with me for a second Dalia but Sudan's
general intelligence is calling the rsf
a rebel group when we hear statements
like that Dahlia it must be very
worrying for the path that the country
is on for the unity of the country at
this point
it's it's frightening it's not just
worrying it's frightening because
they've literally reached the point of
no return this latest escalation shows
that all the talks all the negotiations
have fallen flat they have failed
miserably because until yesterday night
we we were reading and being and being
told that an agreement has been reached
between both sides between the rsf and
the army so then to wake up this morning
and to hear of these crashes goes it
just points a finger that we don't know
what's going to happen next
so far they have I mean we have I
haven't heard of any casualties civilian
casualties nor of um person Army
personal casualties but it is between
them and and we the people are the ones
caught in the middle
and cartoon is a very densely populated
city it's not open spaces so
it so anything that can go wrong it will
be devastating I mean but then again
this is new to us in the center but for
those who've been living in Darfur or in
the nuba mountains this was a norm for
them but for us in the center it's not
and it's
definitely not a pleasant experience to
live to go through
were people prepared for this kind of
situation Dalia where they stocked up
one imagines if this fighting becomes
prolonged
issues like access to food Healthcare
and so on might become complicated
people were not expecting this
is very
something would happen probably over e
because then you know it's the calm you
know it's Aid it's a holiday it comes
out so they will be the perfect time for
them to do anything if any of them if
either side wanted to step it up so we
were really caught up caught by surprise
by what happened this morning and no
we're not prepared I mean I personally
was planning on going buying some
supplies just because it's it's still
Ramadan and we have a heat coming up so
but now we're all stuck at home or stuck
wherever we are and just waiting to see
how it will play out
but I mean it's worried that there's
there's been no uh statements released
from neither the the Troika or the EU I
haven't seen anything so we don't know
what's happening behind closed doors or
they're reaching out are there
negotiations no one knows honestly I
don't think anyone knows what's
happening we keep getting different
reports rsf is in the arm is in the
airport there's shooting in the runways
we don't know what's happening it's just
getting Snippets of information from
social media from friends and contacts
and colleagues and the good thing is so
far the internet hasn't been shut down
so in that sense that's a blessing
but other than that we're just gonna
play it by ear and just see how it fall
you know how it folds out towards the
end you know for the next few hours
we will help you and and the civilians
everyone stay safe though thank you so
much Dalia for talking to us let's go
over to Dwight she's a social activist
and member of geriff now that's of
course a popular non-violent protest
movement so do I bring us up to speed
with where this is leaving you're a
member of one of the the protest
movement forces
has this caught the civilian component
off guard
um how are you and thanks for having me
I don't think it caught anybody by
guards because we've been preparing for
death even the military appearances
um all over in cartoon City for the past
let's say two weeks and given the
statements that coming out from the rsf
and the military this was no surprise
but of course the videos are terrifying
um the sound the sounds of the shooting
and bombing
um because I also live near close to the
um 10 minutes away from the south
cartoon where the first altercation
happened this morning and we can still
we can hear some of the um
shooting and also right now
um we're not worried about no political
agreement because it was clear that it
wasn't going anywhere and we all like in
the neighborhood committees and
Revolution we all was expecting this and
we were seeing it just like the coast of
it didn't I don't think it caught
anybody by guard yeah but does it
undermine the civilian component of the
transitional process when you've got
these two military units going at it now
um
actually we don't we we're still not we
still didn't hear from any civilian
components we read only receiving news
and updates through social media or some
people live near to the um to the fights
and uh we've been following of course on
news um on the news on the TV but so far
we didn't hear from
no civilian
um no civilian parties or like parties
all right thank you so much
there let's uh